[Music]
one reason China's spectacular rise
sometimes alarms its neighbors is that
from the Himalayas to the sea it claims
territory it does not control in the
West China's border dispute with India
is more than a minor cartographic tiff
China claims an area of India that is
twice the size of Switzerland the state
of Arunachal Pradesh for the West China
occupies Indian claim territory next to
Kashmir in 1962 China won a brief war
over the dispute now however a more
immediately dangerous standoff is the
one between China and Japan over
disputed islands in the East China Sea
known as Senkaku in Japan and the D ru
in China the surrounding seas may be
rich in oil and gas which Japan says
provoked China's interest Japan says
they've always been its territory a new
and much more dangerous phase of the
dispute began in 2012 after japan's
government nationalized three of the
islands by buying them from their
private owner infuriated china's since
then has been sending it ships and
planes close to the islands now
challenging even japan's claim to
control them
japan's ally america has confirmed that
its security guarantee does cover the
islands Athan japan were especially
provoked by China's unilateral
announcement in November 2013 of an air
defense identification zone covering the
islands the worry is less of a
deliberate war than an accidental
collision at sea or in the air might
escalate similar fears cloud the
disputes in the South China Sea where
the maritime claims in Southeast Asia
are even more complex and again
competition is made more intense by
speculation about vast potential wealth
in hydrocarbons in May 2014 China moved
a massive oil rig to drill for two
months near the Paracel Islands in
waters claimed by Vietnam China has an
expanding Navy and projects power from
its submarine base on Hainan to the
South China and Vietnam also claimed the
Spratly archipelago as does Taiwan who
claimed in the see mirrors China's but
the Philippines also has a substantial
claim Malaysia and even tiny Brunei have
an interest too in 1995 China evicted
the Philippines from mischief reef and
in 2012 from Scarborough Shoal the
Philippines accuses China of salami
slicing tactics stealthily expanding its
presence in disputed waters in March
2014 it tried to stop the Philippines
from resupplying a small garrison it
maintains on the second Thomas shoal
since then it has appeared to be
building an airstrip on the Johnson
South reef apparently ignoring
international law China and Taiwan point
to a map from the 1940s showing a big
u-shaped nine dashed line around the
edge of the sea all China's they say the
Philippines to China's fury is
challenging this at a UN tribunal a huge
chunk of global trade on almost 1/3 of
Seabourn crude oil passes through the
South China Sea
so these uncertainties worry America as
well as countries nearby the status of
Taiwan is also still unresolved in
practice it has been independent since
1949 but China still insists that one
day it must accept Chinese sovereignty
polls suggest that few in Taiwan are in
any hurry for that day to come China has
never announced the use of force against
Taiwan if necessary and has hundreds of
missiles on its coast trained on the
island no one is asking the Tibetans in
China's West or the largely Muslim we
Gers of the neighboring region of sin
junk whether they want to be part of
China but many of them certainly hanker
after independence that is one reason
why China cannot show weakness on what
it sees as issues of national
sovereignty its expansionist dreams are
haunted by separatist nightmares